latifa bonsoir je suis bon soir vous
allez traduire oui oui vous êtes la
présidente de l'association afghanistan
libre et je dois dire que noël mamère
est un des seuls hommes politiques en
france à avoir été présent à la
manifestation en faveur des femmes
afghanes le 29 septembre dernier revoilà
alors donc latifa publie chez anne
carrière
un livre qui s'appelle visage volet
avoir 20 ans à kaboul qui raconte la vie
avant et après le pouvoir des talibans
interview vérité
[Musique]
on
latifa vous êtes né dans une famille
aisée de kaboul
votre mère était gynécologue votre père
était dans l'import export et vous est
la dernière de cinq enfants
vous êtes né en 1981 ce qui veut dire
que vous n'avez connu que la guerre
alors dit à force de vivre dans la
guerre nous étions devenus indifférents
à la tragédie de notre pays nous étions
anesthésiés au point de ne pas voir
arriver
l'ultime menace les talibans c'est à
dire que derrière cette guerre il y
avait quelque chose d'encore plus graves
qui arrivait alors jusqu'à l'âge de
saison et malgré le fait que votre pays
soit dans la guerre vous avez une vie
assez insouciante
d'une certaine façon au dimanche jusqu'à
l'âge de ces enjeux j'avais une
adolescence insouciante
j'ai été à quelques mois de passer mon
bac à l'orias j'avais des amis garçons
filles et surtout j'étais mal je m'étais
inscrite à la faculté de journalisme
pour devenir journaliste oui c'est vrai
qu'avant l'arrivée des talibans vous
participiez des rencontres sportives des
rencontres culturelles
vous parlez de mode avec vos amis vous
alliez au cinéma vous vouliez devenir
journaliste effectivement si tu savais
partie non ça faisait partie de ma vie
avant
mais 16 ans et on parlait de mode avec
les amis surtout on écoutait beaucoup de
musique la musique c'était très
important pour nous voilà et pendant ce
temps là avec l'aide des américains avec
l'aide des usa le pakistan venait en
aide à la mise en place des talibans
[Musique]
dassault se mord la queue
les statues en bois les passes on a dit
que maradona - dj avant l arrivée des
talibans je m'intéressais pas beaucoup à
la politique et je dois le dire ça me
dépasse un petit peu je m'intéressais
pas mais voir ces étrangers dans mon
pays ça m'a permis de m'intéresser un
peu plus à la géopolitique et de voir
ces étrangers sur notre sol est voir
d'où il venait et ça ça fait encore plus
mal effectivement alors le 27 septembre
1996 les talibans entre dans le câble
houle
les écoles sont fermées les femmes sont
humiliés insultés enfermé est obligé de
porter ce que vous portez ce soir c'est
à dire le tchadri sharks au balcon
malade mais cela zykë et à que charles
beau choc hassan daoud ya un soldat
guinée a connu pour 27 septembre
c'est vrai que c'était le jour qu'il a
basculé la la vie de toutes les femmes à
cabo toutes les jeunes filles et cette
ville est devenue une ville en deuil
du jour au lendemain et moi j'étais plus
latifa de la veille et j'ai changé en un
jour effectivement comme toutes les
jeunes filles 27 septembre 96 alors ces
talibans sont pas tous afghans ni même
tous patchoune il ya des pakistanais il
ya des arabes
ils ont une chose en commun c'est d'être
barbu et d'avoir une barbe qui va
mesurer la longueur de la main
amis africains ghana au togo assani
tidjani sur tout ce qu' ils ont aussi
c'est un regard atroce c'est affreux qui
vous brisent le qui vous glacent le sang
seul instant il suffit de croiser ce
regard et je peux vous dire que vous
l'oubliez plus jamais la première chose
qui vous étonne vraiment c'est que les
talibans exhibe la dépouille de l'ex
président najib ou là qui a été lynché
avant d'être pendu et vous le voyez avec
des cigarettes enfoncé dans la bouche et
des billets qui dépasse de ses poches et
pour vous c'est un spectacle ignoble
c'était encore plus ignoble de voir ça
et surtout la sauvagerie des aliments
puisque docteur n'est du goût là
qu'était le président était un pachtoune
et qu'il pensait qu'avec les talibans
ils allaient tous trouvé un allié et le
voir pondu dès le premier jour ça nous a
montré à quel point ils sont capables du
pire c'est talbot et puis viennent les
consignes des talibans les décrets
respecter l'avalanche des interdits les
filles et les femmes n'ont plus le droit
de travailler à l'extérieur les lois
commencé à venir les unes après les
autres
pas seulement pour les femmes mais aussi
pour les hommes parce que le sort des
hommes étaient payés pas mieux non plus
parce que toute l'administration étaient
fermées donc les hommes non plus n'avait
pas le droit de travailler puisque
aucune administration nous fonctionner à
part le ministère de la promotion de la
vertu et en tennis ouais alors
les femmes ne peuvent plus sortir sans
être revêtue du tchad riz et sans être
accompagnées d'un homme
chawki aloui alors imaginer le sort de
toutes ces veuves qui depuis 18 années
de guerre parce qu'avant les talibans y
avait dix huit années de guerre qui
n'avaient pas d'homme et qui n'avait pas
de mari ou pas de frère avait perdu
imaginer le sort de ces femmes à quel
point elle se faisait humilier et toutes
ces femmes qui pour exister dans la rue
simple pour faire une simple course a
besoin d'une présence masculine
il y en avait pas dans les familles
kaboul n'avait pas dans toutes les
familles de présence masculine alors
fini le maquillage fini le rouge à
lèvres fini le vernis à ongles et si on
porte du vernis à ongles on peut avoir
les doigts coupés
c'était un dd des histoires rapportées
par une de mes amies proches j'ai rêvé
vu justement les doigts coupés de cette
femme et moi je vous raconte l'anecdote
delà de cette femme avec ses chaussures
blanches mais la première fois que je
suis sorti dans la rue etc ce qui m'a
décidé de ne plus sortir dans la partir
de ce jour là c'était de rencontrer
cette femme dans la rue qui se faisait
frapper par ces fous et rempli de plomb
au pied parce qu'elle portait des
chaussures blanches qui était la même
couleur que la couleur des drapeaux les
talibans et qu'il fallait que ça
devienne rouge comme c'est comme avec la
couleur de sens où aucun médecin homme
ne doit toucher le corps d'une femme et
comme les femmes ne peuvent plus
travailler
elles ne sont plus soignés donc elle
meurt comme avocat médecin ne pouvait
toucher les femmes et
moi même c'était juste un exemple pour
me faire soigner j'ai dit j'ai dû
quitter kaboul pour partir de là
peshawar au pakistan pour me faire
soigner parce que le médecin n'avait pas
le droit de me touche et me soigner
interdit d'écouter de la musique
interdit de faire des photos ci dessus
12e et un voile et la musique était
interdite dès le début ce qui nous a le
plus touché nous les jeunes parce que ça
faisait partie de notre vie quotidienne
mais malgré ça on avait quand même notre
résistance était d'écouter de la musique
clandestine et des quais d'avoir des
cassettes et des à l'intérieur de la
maison la peur au ventre en écouter
quand même la musique alors les non
musulmans sont obligés de revêtir des
vêtements jaune ce qui rappelle ici de
bons souvenirs interdit de vendre des
sous vêtements féminins
ces objets étaient considérés comme un
des objets profane est alors le plus
étonnant pourquoi interdit de sifflets
et de posséder des bouilloires sifflante
ça rappelait les sons musicaux et ça
rappelle pour hausser la voix du satin
interdit de posséder des chiens ou des
oiseaux et vous êtes obligé de dire
adieu à votre chien bingo non seulement
j en ai dû se séparer de nos animaux
mais sachez que le sort de beaucoup
d'entre nous étaient bien pires que ces
animaux dont on était obligé de se
séparer
voilà et puis à le tchadri donc avant
les talibans quand vous voyez des femmes
revêtues du tchadri vous les ateliers
les les bouteilles vous les ateliers les
choux fleurs à l'envers vous appeliez
les sacs à provisions
je pense qu'en se moquer de ces femmes
c'est pauvre femme avec mes amis pas
seulement moi mais mes amis jamais on
était loin de se douter qu'un jour on
serait nous mêmes des choux fleurs
alors au début vous restez chez vous et
puis voulait pas sortir vêtus du tchad
riz à kaboul
et puis un jour devant l'insistance
d'une amie vous essayez et vous dit ce
n'est pas un vêtement c'est une prison
[Musique]
seul quand je discutais toutes ces
jeunes filles beaucoup de jeunes filles
pas les femmes nous agit mais surtout
les jeunes filles
il faut vraiment qu'on attend d'une
excuse pour se faire soigner ou une
vraie excuse pour sortir de la maison
parce qu'on se dit sortir d'une prison
dans une autre au moins dans la nôtre
l'intérieur on n'est pas obligé de venir
nous frappe et humilié alors qu'avec
notre prison le tchadri on n'est pas
l'abri de l'humiliation quatre mois donc
après l'arrivée des talibans vous sortez
enfin et vous dites pourtant ce qui
prouve votre état d'esprit vous dites si
mon futur mari me demandait de porter un
foulard ou un tchador hors de la maison
j'accepterai sans problème y est une
norme seulement de l'ébauché mais la
passion déjà le tchador quand je faisais
ma prière dans mon coin
donc effectivement je suis une musulmane
croyante pratiquante
oui nous devons partager le même point
de vue et savoir pourquoi je le porte
et pour rien au monde je perdrais aucune
autre de mes libertés
et puis elle est violent un jour 3 jeune
fille arrive chez vous pour être soigné
par votre mère d'une façon clandestine
et vous découvrez à ce qu'on laquelle
ont été victimes non seulement de viols
et de mutilations et dégâts générés à
tabou de queiroz a dit gay marriage is
and abou dhabi
sam zarka saadi est nommé connaître aux
hommes et à gilles desjardins
effectivement qu'on était capable qu'on
pouvait un être humain homme pouvait
être capable de traiter avec autant de
violence et de haine une femme c'est
quelque chose je vous assure qu est
inimaginable temps qu'on le voit pas
exception peut pas imaginer qu'un ne
peut faire autant de mal gratuitement
pendant ce temps le ministre de la santé
des talibans est reçu à paris dans le
pays des droits de l'homme
et quand vous apprenez ça quelle est
votre réaction à motonat ma rose à
gauche je suis à voir ce modèle est à la
fraude et au bout d un bois djibouti
comment ramener la gauche mais la radio
clandestine à cette époque là donc
c'était notre seule occupation aussi
d'écouter cette radio de chercher les
informations
je vous raconte pas la tristesse des
gens à kaboul de voir cette propagande
faite par les talibans de voir je
représente enterrement qui était reçu
dans un pays européen
qui plus est le pays de la démocratie
des droits de l'homme je peux vous dire
qu'ils ont fait de la propagande pour
nous dire qu'ils ont été reconnus ici et
là vous quitter l'afghanistan avec votre
père votre mère et une amie une fatwa
est lancé contre vous est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez peur de cette
fatwa à nohic et en vraiment encore
icade à bout d'un nadal j'ai moins peur
pour moi pour moi plus j'ai plus peur
pour toutes ces femmes qui m'ont choisie
pour venir porter leur message ici et
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui la balle est
donc j'ai aucune nouvelle je sais pas ce
qu'elle devienne c'est pour elle que
j'ai plus peur parce que c'est elle qui
sont en danger
latifa aujourd'hui des gens en france
vous regardent des gens à l'étranger
vous regarde dans beaucoup de pays du
monde
qu'avez vous à dire aux gens qui vous
regardent mais un barème amont mais
caron ni eau ni à wall membres à son
examen avant d'être embauché en
affichant dès lors dire que jusqu'à
jusqu'à quand ce silence cette
indifférence contre la faim de marianne
qui aujourd'hui souffrent la bataille
contre la faim de morgane c'est une
femme aussi comme n'importe quelle femme
dans le monde si un jour ce sort vous
touche
ça m'étonnerait que vous acceptiez ce
sort ligh je pense que vous serez bien
content deux camps soient toutes les
femmes dans le monde viennent vous vient
de vous aider à l'essai ça fait
longtemps ça fait trop longtemps
aujourd'hui l'afghanistan et les afghans
surtout les avocats n'ont besoin qu'on
penserait blessure aura lieu si
quelqu'un vous poser des questions à
latifa noël c'est isabelle philippe
rolland dottikon c'est absolument
terrifiant et moi je tire on peut que
vous exprimer notre respect et notre
solidarité vous demandez ce que nous
pouvons faire nous citoyens pour vous
pour vous aider j'ai besoin de
l'éducation c'est la base même de ce
dont nous voulons aujourd'hui en
afghanistan
aidez nous à voir la paix dans notre
pays pour qu'on puisse reconstruire déjà
aujourd'hui vous allez nous avons
désormais très bien décédé depuis des
années déjà vous pouvez aider ces zones
là c'est aussi un combat comme un autre
jour de poser des questions à latifa
d'abord je ne comprends pas comment vous
avez pu en arriver là c'est une question
cruel peut-être mais la femme toujours
eu au sein de la société
un pouvoir même si c'était un pouvoir
cacher il ya un pouvoir sur les sur les
maris un pouvoir sur les frères ya un
pouvoir sur les ficelles donne la vie
donc allez quand même l'intermédiaire
absolument indispensable d'une société
comment se peut-il que c'est un tel
pouvoir qui est qui et lanteri nation de
la lutte dans l'essex au dans le sens le
plus barbare puisse être installé voilà
ma question je comprends pas je ne
comprends pas je m'envoie dit la meute à
la jungle avec andrew jarrett aliments
sont arrivés au pouvoir en afghanistan
il y avait déjà dix huit années de
guerre derrière ce peuple donc il y
avait déjà dix huit années de guerre
derrière ce peuple donc le peuple était
détruit avec l'invasion soviétique
et quand ils sont arrivés il y avait
déjà un peuple détruits et les talibans
pour la plupart sont des jeunes prélever
tout tout petit et qui sont élevés dans
des madrassas en dehors de tout amour
maternel en dehors de toute présence et
qui ne savent absolument pas ce que vous
dire l'amour et la chaleur d'une famille
donc forcément c'est là où on fabrique
sont pas des talibans ne se sont pas
révoltés contre cet état de fait
parce qu'en même sans leurs femmes et il
est bon d alcool femmes les hommes et
les femmes se révoltent tous les jours
contre les talibans et ne serait-ce qu'
on est quand même aujourd'hui au bout de
cinq semaines il
un mec comme l'armée américaine n'arrive
pas à toucher les talibans nous ça fait
sept ans qu'on se bat contre les taliban
et contre le terrorisme et nous avons
quand même des zones libres où il ya 5
millions de personnes qui habitent
on continue à construire des écoles des
hôpitaux et à donner du travail aux
femmes et ça veut bien dire qu'on a
réussi là où aujourd'hui il est plus
grande armée du monde échoue il ya
d'autres choses il expliqué certaines
des hommes talibans vis-à-vis des femmes
parce que s'ils détruisent toutes les
femmes comment ils vont se procurer
comment ils vont continuer leur dynastie
ce qui ne s'était pas c'est pas du tout
c'est une machination de l'état
l'immense et les pakistanais aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont reçus par le quai d'orsay ce
sont aussi les arabes d'arabie saoudite
et les émirats puisque c'est les trois
pays qui reconnaissent le régime des
talibans où ils ont leurs ambassades
aujourd'hui et le but c'est pas de
prendre le sepa de procréer ou quoi que
ce soit le but c'est de reprendre le
territoire afghan
donc le meilleur façon de détruire une
nation c'est détruire sa femme donc par
la destruction de la femme afghane ont
détruit la nation afghane et on a le
territoire libre d'afghanistan qui est
quand même l'objet de convoitises depuis
des centaines et des milliers de
tchèques et bas dernière question
les français se demandent ce qu'il faut
faire il se demande s'il faut soutenir
les américains ils se demandent s'il ya
d'autres moyens d'action
vous qui êtes afghane et qui militait
pour un afghanistan libre et
démocratique que nous conseillez-vous
c'est très simple il faut déjà une
pression il faut arrêter de 2,2 jouer
avec les gens en recevant celui dont les
avants demande aujourd'hui qu'ils soient
devant le tribunal international c'est
le pakistan et le président musharraf
aujourd'hui il est reçu comme un de nos
meilleurs amis comme c'était le cas il
ya quelques mois pour les talibans donc
ça c'est insupportable pour les
allemands ça peut pas passer alors que
les afghans en afghanistan la semaine
dernière me demandais tu vas faire
quelque chose là-bas pour leur dire
qu'il faut mettre le pakistan devant le
tribunal international
aujourd'hui il est ici au quai d'orsay
donc je me sens un peu faible et de
l'autre côté il ya des il faut faire de
l'humanitaire dans les zones où les gens
sont en train de mourir avec le froid
qui approche dans les zones où souvent
c'est fait c'est pas très facile d'accès
pour les ong donc il faut y aller mais
surtout il faut aider les zones libres
dans les projets de développement
il faut faire en sorte que ces gens
continuent dans leur élan d'espoir et
qui continuent à être opérationnel le
jour où le pays libre ces femmes
continuent à être opérationnel le jour
où ce pays est libre
je suis allé dans un camp de réfugiés
une femme qui me regarde dans les yeux
me dit j'ai perdu mon mari mon frère
mais tu pourras faire quelque chose pour
la petite pour qu'elles aillent à
l'école donc ça veut dire qu'elle elle
continue à croire louis si on n'a pas le
droit de les abonnés auxquels il faut
soutenir les américains alors puisqu'ils
sont blur leur but c'est de ça que je
pose laquelle je pose la question
puisque leur but c'est de détruire les
talibans alors faut-il soutenir les
américains quelle est l'opinion d'une
afghane je pense que l'opinion d'une
afghane et des avancées que l'europe
puisse enfin trouver une identité et que
ne suivent pas les américains
aveuglément etc les avants qu'ils
attendent beaucoup plus des européens et
des français aujourd'hui
depuis toujours on a dit les français
ont idéalisé massoud et tout le monde
pense que la france a beaucoup pédemas
août ce qui est pas ce qui est pas le
cas ce qui est pas vrai comme vous avez
très bien dit monsieur mamère dans un
article que trois mois après sa
réception et si rien n'avait bougé pour
l'alliance
donc on l'a dit pendant des années a été
victime de notre grand amour avec la
france mais c'est pas pour autant que la
france nous a aidés merci
[Applaudissements]
oui
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh ben dis donc voilà donc c'était le
témoignage de latifa et c'est un petit
peu finalement grâce à la télévision
comme si pendant la guerre on avait vu
des gens qui seraient sortis d'un camp
de concentration pour venir témoigner la
télévision donc là on peut pas dire
qu'on savait pas puisque on sait voilà
c'est que la grande différence avec ce
qui s'est passé entre 1942 et 1945 voilà
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou